Hello everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
My, my, my, my.
Yeah.
Welcome in.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome to Leaf It Allowed.
I guess this is a leaf power wash simulator, which I'm
totally for.
I kind of wanted, I honestly, I had this as like a, what's
it called?
A throwaway game, I'll call it for travel, right?
Like if I needed something to stream that wasn't super
intensive while I was traveling.
I had this on the back burner, but also I was like, I
haven't, there's a couple of long streams.
this week so but in the end it ended up being too low energy
streams.
I did hightail too.
Hello me, Tao, and I boo's like you!
How you make sure you keep that lawn clean.
The HOAs have been bugging me about it.
No, no HOAs in this vicinity.
Facility.
Neighborhood.
Yeah, Doki collab was so long.
But I guess that maybe was the only long one i did this week
whatever it doesn't matter who cares i just i wanted to
chill before the chaos of densetsu collab later which there
will be a collab later me and densetsu dot exe on the
densetsu youtube channel we'll be writing into it so um but
if you're a vod watcher then go check it out because it will
be fun make like a tree and get out of here mcfly
Is that what he says?
What if I'm not a VOD watcher?
Then you should go right after this stream.
Actually, I probably won't stream up to the collab.
That's what he says.
What is it supposed to be?
Make like a tree and...
Shake it.
Make like a tree and sprout.
Make like a tree and stand there.
Oh, leaf!
But trees have leaves.
Vivi Cortex with a vibe gift!
Make like a tree and...
Photosynthesize.
But they make the leaves.
So they do leaf.
leaf verb okay guys I'm leafing I'm leaf I'm doing leaf
they're they're coming out of my fingers I'm doing leaf is
it I am leaf I am leaf I'm leafing it about as funny as a
screen door on a battleship what my Joker but Free talk's
funny?
Anyway, we're gonna start a new game.
This is this seems to be a pretty zatsu.
My head hurts so much.
Pretty free talk heavy stream.
I fell into a coma yet another time and doctors still can't
figure out why.
And how come there are so many leaves in here again?
Wait, why am I?
Will I ever manage to clean up this cursed yard?
I'm also not pressing continue.
It's just doing it on its own.
What?
Why have I had another cup?
I'm afraid it's been nine years.
Imagine the leaf buildup in nine years.
Branch and owl.
To seal or not to seal.
Pick up the leaves and dump them one by one or unlock the
bag tying ability.
I'm this actually makes so much sense we don't know how to
tie bags because we've been in a coma we've literally lost
all our motor skills by cleaning up the entire porch and
throw it away all at once hold and run I did okay so before
literally the stream um I watched the trailer for this game
I hadn't watched it before I just thought that it was like a
leaf cleaning simulator but there was something kind of
mysterious they were implying so i'm very curious it's my
birthday today and one year anniversary of my first super
chat hope you and i must have a great day looking forward to
the stream and the dance and took with the daily dial thank
you happy birthday happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you daily day oh happy birthday to you
oh happy birthday thank you so much for the gift nine year
coma that's unbelievable but yeah let the inlets do the
heavy leaf thing they suck up nearby leaves and convert them
into check leaves the in-game currency oh Use a rake or leaf
blower to herd leaves into an inlet's range.
Then watch your pockets grow.
Fluid picker?
I have zero sense.
Meant to cleaning my yard on my birthday.
And that guy's birthday!
Detective!
Wait, is it Detective Koo?
Happy birthday!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you!
you happy birthday detective clue happy birthday to you
happy birthday just wanted to say i quite enjoyed the aurora
cam the other night wasn't it great i love that live cam one
by one oh my god okay
yeah i love that live cam it's so It's so stinking good.
Sprint ability.
What is that noise?
Oh!
I have to get you...
Wait.
I'm like clicking.
Oh!
Repair.
Is it saying that I can't do it, maybe?
Halo, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Wait, so how do I make any money at all, then?
in the beginning is what I'm curious about.
Milky Way in.
Very slowly.
Oh, I got very little.
Oh, buddies.
Okay.
All right, we gotta pick up something.
What if I had, like, an auto-clicker?
What if I use an auto-clicker, right?
oh oh i hold it down there we go okay so i can hold up the
50 at a time right now we just gotta make some cash money
any any sorts mint has no sense but i can't help but
remember the one part of over the garden wall i have no
sense no sense at all i think of it too oh my gosh i have
like a 1.9 leaf per second right right now we need to get
higher almost two leaves per second i think some of the
upgrades are like an auto clicker this is kind of great
though i think i can really get behind this wait is there
more back here oh i have to unlock i can see it i can see it
i saw some uh the reviews this game said that it's not a you
can like 100 the game in not a long time so yeah i gotta up
my my stats though 1.9 leaf per second is crazy okay you
can't hold down the click you have to keep continuously
clicking the door is a paywall i can't even run i have to
pay for that It's kind of wild.
It's kind of cozy though.
How's the weather where you guys are?
Is it very cold if you are in the United States of America?
It's cold.
All right, so I have, oh, I had 69 cents, nice.
We can upgrade.
Dexterity reduces the intervals between picking up leaves.
Greedy grasp.
Why click the 100 times when you can just hold the...
Hey.
Nice.
Okay, we got some upgrades already.
Oh, my God.
Invest, invest, invest.
I'm not even having to click anymore.
This is great.
Paying for quality of life.
I can see the floor.
Extremely cold today.
Yeah.
Oh.
Something just popped up.
Oh, I think I can get another upgrade.
6.9 leaves per second.
This is not just a cleaning game.
This is like getting this guy's motor skills backup type of
game like we're learning how to be human again actually it
was the hospital that dumped all these leaves here to try
and this is my physical therapy
maybe rehab leaf trainer they're gonna give me back problems
and so i'm having to i'm gonna i'm having to like lean over
so They will, I go from one problem to the next.
I can't, I click control.
It doesn't, it like yells at me.
Reduces the intervals.
Let's try that.
Oh yeah.
Eight leaves per second.
That's how they get you.
Leveling up like a true RPG.
A true physical therapy recovery adventure.
Okay.
I could almost...
I feel like that could be like a game concept.
Like...
Like someone who...
Like has to remember how to...
Not remember, but like it's like I've been in a coma.
I have to learn how to see.
My body does not remember how to see.
My eyes have been closed for too long.
I must unlock the ability.
It's in spawn.
It's not sad.
Breaking leaves is actually bad for fireflies.
Why now?
I would need to...
I wish I could increase my capacity.
Wait, I think we can get...
How much are these?
75 cents.
An average bag for average leaf enjoyers.
200 leaves!
So if I buy it...
Oh!
Now I have 200.
Capacity.
We'll do leaves that are like really far away, right?
Also bad for grass since it doesn't insulate ground from
cold and snow.
That's so sad.
Wait, so we're damaging the environment.
Leaves are natural.
Don't leaf it alone.
Wait, I had no idea about that.
I figured that like, I thought it would be bad because it's
like...
You're denying...
You're denying the leaves of their, um, like, uh, what's the
word?
Can I jump?
Oh, I have to unlock this, okay.
Denying them the, uh, like, the leaves to decompose, and so
you get the nutrients, right?
That's what I thought.
But it's also just fun to make a big old pile and jump in
it.
Wait, so this is, like, harming the environment.
simulator go back in your coma I'm just kidding what do you
think you're doing they woke up and chose violence against
the earth I
wonder if we eventually start getting paid more per leaf
could be huge I think to fix this it's three bucks oh it's
free this one was three dollars
It's sucking it up.
Free bucks.
My leaves are becoming more valuable because they're a
scarcity.
Someone's trying to buy leaves, but other people are picking
them all up.
Other people, aka me.
And there might be like some fall festival and they're like,
we need thousands of leaves!
Thousands for the children to jump into the piles.
Pass me some good luck.
I'm being stuck at work cleaning up during after the
blizzard.
Probably the next week?
No!
But...
Good luck.
Free bucks.
What do you clean up after a blizzard?
Are you shoveling snow?
Snow, snow.
We need more snow.
Indeed.
Actually, I think we don't need any more snow.
I can't stop coding that recently.
Oh my gosh, there's even leaves in here.
Oh, sneaky.
No, no, no.
Not on my watch.
Yeah.
No more snow ever, please.
I think I'm done with...
I'm quite finished with...
With...
winter.
I'm ready for another season.
I think it's come to that point.
Even though I feel like we still have many more season, not
many more, but we have a couple more months of the season.
All in favor of changing the weather?
The freeze is coming.
No, I'll have.
No freeze.
The freeze is here.
I just hope I don't lose power.
I found out about jumping in a pile of leaves if you're
wearing earbuds take them out otherwise you'll be searching
for teeny tiny earbuds in a big leaf pile literal needle in
a haystack can it just stay autumn I know autumn is really
truly the ideal season but as an idle fan I must say winter,
not winter, sorry, summer is great.
And I say that, okay, but ice skating is fun.
I thought about going ice skating this year.
Or last year, I guess.
This season.
The winter.
I thought about it.
But I never, I didn't actually get around to it.
I do like ice skating, though.
But, I don't know, I'll just go to a roller rink.
It's not the same, but I'll, you know.
Contradiction.
Spot the layer.
It's a point and detective game with real people maybe as a
co-lab a co-lab oh like uh wait that sounds fine thank you
shark uh so because i used to do like inline skating um i
really you know i enjoy going to like a roller rink and
stuff i'll have fun with that contradiction is great oh we
could do a next Weak?
Maybe.
Oh, liar.
Wait, spot, oh, it's a liar.
Wait, let me write it down.
Contradiction, spot the layer.
Wait, I think we can buy a rake soon.
I think it was $7.
749 $50 for the leaf I mean that makes sense but it still
makes me sad Large leaf bag 500 leaves Wait I think I should
buy this first No We'll buy the rake and make big money And
then we will Oh I collected a bonk It's cute Wait there's
leaves here even
We'll buy the rake first and then we'll start making big fat
big big stacks big fat stacks really fast
i'm like sticking by the what's it called we're branching
out from we're branch make like a tree and branch out from
the from the trash can
okay soon oh wait wait it was 7 48 right okay we got it
Yippee!
Okay.
Uh.
Oh.
Okay, here we go.
Yes!
No.
Go back.
Go in.
Come on.
Does it have like a cooldown?
What is this?
Oh, I have to look down, that's why.
Yes, yes, yes, everybody gets sucked.
I think Denzatsu.exe should also have a yearly summer song
and video.
Well.
I think my next song, though, will be a summer song.
Which I'm very excited about.
Yeah, as an idol fan, summer is great.
It's not perfect, but this is definitely a system.
You like idols?
I love idols.
It's working so far.
Yeah, it is.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
There we go.
All right, let's start making...
What if I make a big pile?
How is, I wonder what the biggest pile I could make it.
Ooh, it's getting red.
I'm gonna jump in it.
There was a Shrek game where Donkey had a line like, now
let's make it, make like a tree and get in our onion
carriage.
Oh, Donkey.
That guy's so silly.
Why is it so flat?
Don't talk about my Oshi like that.
Minto's really raking in the cash.
Oh, yeah.
Denzetsu Beach episode.
That would be so fun.
Minto looking in the mirror.
I think I'm normal.
I think I'm average.
Not too big.
Never too small.
Why is it so flat though?
It's supposed to be a pile of leaves.
Getting closer to that two-year mark.
Oh yeah!
We're gonna start seeing people in the upcoming months
turning rainbow.
I think that's a two-year one.
Rainbow.
years two years
it's my birthday tomorrow gonna get that early birthday
speedy fire happy birthday but it's your birthday tomorrow
are you gonna be doing stuff are you gonna be out and about
in the town having a fun time senchi thank you so much for
the 10 gifts Do you guys know the Denshi name?
That is for, like, fans of Densetsu.exe?
I came up with that.
It was a stroke of genius.
So you know how we're, like, protectors of Akiba and all.
It's inspired by the name Senshi, like, Warrior, like, you
know, Sailor Senshi.
part is like the electric so it's it's kind of like it's
like a multiple meaning right so den she the the word also
means like electron in japanese like you know and then but
so it's pronounced like that but it uses the kanji for like
so it's like essentially electric warrior You guys are also
warriors.
With us.
Like Den-Shi.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I love Japanese wordplay.
Yeah, it was my stroke of genius.
I was like, what do you guys think?
Because we are Den-Satsu.
Dot EXE.
You are Den-Shi.
No, well, thank you so much for that one.
Thank you.
Clever.
So we are common riders.
I wonder if you guys, if Denchi should have a mascot,
though.
It'd be kind of cute.
Yeah, like has multiple meanings, so I thought it was kind
of fun to...
to use it but if you know it does require a bit of
explanation what the hell Steiner get out of here why is the
Densetsu account gifting memberships
go Lord finger Institute MVP's brings such a sparkle to my
eyes yeah I really hope we can get the music video to 100k
views i wanted to see if we could try and do it before the
new year and then i forgot to like campaign for it i forgot
to be like come on guys let's get it to 100k my bad okay
this is 50 oh yeah i was gonna buy this but right now I'm
just raking.
Raking in the cash.
We can buy, we can fix this too.
How goes the raking is great.
Thank you for dropping by.
Thanks for stopping by.
Whoa, what's this?
Is this another collectible?
Eww.
We need more upgrades.
I forgot about these.
Journal.
Wait!
Jump into a big leaf pile!
Find a way into the garage.
Don't hurry unless you can.
Go shed shopping.
I need it too!
Jump into...
Wait!
So there...
Oh, whoops, sorry, my bad.
There we go.
So I do need to...
Okay, maybe in another area we can do it.
Because I don't...
I mean, there surely is a thousand leaves here, but...
I tried!
I tried.
I said my biggest pile is...
14.
What do you mean by that?
This is way more than 14!
Hello, game?
Maybe it needs to be a tighter pile.
while okay hold on let's we'll try the other side we'll try
the other side the other side surely has over a thousand can
i even oh i can jump
oh number go up number go up thank you so much for the thank
you i
wonder if we can get rake upgrades because like a huge wide
break.
Make her wide.
You can.
Oh, okay, I can.
Find a way into the garage.
It says don't...
Oh!
My moving speed went up.
Nice.
Oh, front yard is 100%.
But, oh, I see, I see.
This is the entrance.
That's why it's different.
Oh, interesting.
Find a way into the garage.
Can I climb?
Can I crouch?
No.
There is another vent here.
It needs to be repaired.
We'll make the pile right in front of it.
Okay, watch this, guys.
We'll make a giant pile right in front of it while it's not
repaired yet.
And we'll jump in it.
And then...
We'll fix it.
She's cooking.
Someone cooked here.
you guys i haven't been drawing so much it's maybe making me
a little sad and i was thinking about it i was like you know
right now i have a lot kind of that i've been working on so
i haven't really had time to draw but when i was watching
breaking bad i would just like put on an episode and draw
and i was like man i just need to have like another show
that i put on and can
you know
up a common rider yeah but i have to like i want to watch
common rider
also um but it's just been i've been so busy to do anything
to do it but after well i would say after saving that
didn't go up anymore
I have to catch up on common rather.
I would say after my jazz show, but even not, I don't think
so.
It's even gonna get busier after that probably.
Still normal streams, just busy on the back end.
If you know, you know.
Actually, none of you should know.
Why is it not going up?
What am I doing wrong?
My birthday is Monday.
Should I get choco cake?
Yeah!
Wait!
Who said that?
Oh my gosh, shiver!
Happy early birthday!
Sorry I won't be streaming then.
Ask tomorrow for a birthday.
I'll do a little dance.
I'll be in 3D.
If you don't know, you don't Oh no.
Speaking of Toku, have you heard about the upcoming Gavin
Infinity?
I haven't.
If you liked Foundation, then I would recommend Altered
Carbon.
What's Foundation?
Look at my pile is great!
Maybe I need to make a different pile.
Let's fix this real quick.
Oh wow, that was so anti-climactic.
Taking place of Super Sentai.
Ooh!
What?
Rake upgrades.
Wait, is that under here?
No stinking way.
Leaf stickiness.
Improves how leaves follow the rake.
Sweep radius.
Makes the rake affect more leaves at once.
Wait, we'll do both.
well i need to make a new pile i think
i think the other pile was too small or rather not too small
i think they were like you've jumped in this pile too many
times maybe i need to make it like huge and then jump in it
once get more viewers in a stream than days in a year it's
always someone's birthday yeah i guess I guess that would be
true, huh?
Do I have more viewers than number of days in a year?
How many days in a year are there?
365!
I do?
Yippee!
It was my birthday two weeks ago.
Tier 9!
Why didn't you tell me?
At least 14 viewers.
No, no.
You must be of age to watch.
If you are 14, get out of here.
I'm not raunchy or anything, but I ain't for kids.
There are 65 viewers in the world.
I'm old Minky.
Okay, what?
You want a trophy for it or what?
Here we go.
What the?
What do you mean?
Okay, no.
This is BS.
Forced you!
Get serious, but...
Okay, I'm getting serious.
I'm trying.
I wonder if like in these leaves is a key to get...
Well, the garage doesn't seem to be needing a key.
That was actually Nimi that said she watched Foundation.
Foundation and Altered Carbon are both good shows if
you're...
Oh!
Oh, that's so funny.
You're all good.
We turned on this one.
This is why I have no grass.
Because I'm just...
I'm raking up all the leaves.
They can't live.
Okay.
Green women.
Yeah.
I started that pluribus show.
I only watched the first episode.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll watch the second episode after
after the densest of collab today.
Viewer discretion is advised.
Streamer may use strongholds.
language such as BS and heck please remove children from the
audience well I don't use a strong language usually because
I find that to be uncouth in front of a Goshi Jinsema and
Ojosema I try to be a good maid maybe
I need like the sticky Upgrade.
To help with making a bigger pile.
Talking about Dogen's though is fine.
That's my mama's work.
That's literally, I am being her number one fan.
I'm being her cheerleader.
We're over bros a lot.
Happy birthday.
It's her art Yeah
I'm trying to be a good daughter And Advertise her work Now
I'm being shamed for it Okay let's see if I really Sweep
these good
It doesn't even come up Well you are your mama's work of
art.
I am, I am!
My TV might have a crush on you because when I open the
YouTube app it plays one of your past dreams in full screen
before getting to the menu.
Regardless of how long the TV has been turned off or what I
last watched on YouTube.
What the heck?
Bigger.
I jumped a little off.
Oh!
I even got an achievement for it!
let's go find a way into the garage and collect mysterious
photos all right now
nice raking the cash raking the cash
tv is getting parasocial tv is haunted i have that effect
that's haunting effect yeah once you're just like oh yeah i
found a new vtuber she's kind of cool and then you're just
like oh yeah the vtuber i found i can't get her out of my
brain let's finish this area and then we'll finish that area
oh i'm sorry i'm a little like i usually i like to finish
one area and then move on to the next i'm a little all over
the place
It's true.
Who knows?
Maybe you like getting the life sucked out of you.
Maybe it's a little bit of an addicting feeling.
I don't know what it feels like.
It might tickle.
Or hurt.
Like how it hurts.
Well, I mean, it's gonna hurt a little bit.
It's your life being drained.
I joined Strayed during a strange sentence.
I feel like that's quite normal, no?
I mean, I'm a ghost.
Instead of parasocial, I want to play the stranding with
them.
Oh, no, play DS with them.
Hey, can I buy your modded...
For captured DS.
Oh, wait, what do you mean?
It has an effect that makes me parasocial.
Paranormal.
Ain't that getting freaky?
More likely than you think.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop my freak.
I won't apologize for my freak.
I'm a freak and I'm proud.
You guys are all freaks, too.
You're here, after all.
She's super freaker.
I'm...
Life is more fun if you're freaky.
I, well, I assume.
Afterlife is more fun if you're freaky.
Assume it works the same.
I think that was freaky, but equally sweet and wholesome.
No, I'm evil.
I'm evil.
Hey, hey, where are you going?
Into the...
Yippee!
Gotta go fast!
I can sprint!
now.
Oh my god, it's huge.
Huge.
We could sprint.
We leaf, we rake, we piles.
Music.
What the hell?
Sprinto minto.
There's gotta be a key in here.
Or something, right?
Find a way into the garage.
I'm remembering bodily.
remembering my bodily functions.
Like, run.
Is that a function, or?
I will just pick this up by hand.
No elp.
Yeah, no elp, no elp, no elp.
These are cheap.
Maybe it's hidden under, like, a...
Well, I keep thinking it's gotta be a key.
I'm not quite sure, actually.
It is a function, yeah?
Okay, see?
Legs.
I'm glad that I can sometimes have legs.
Legs are sexy.
I get it.
I understand it, Granon.
They really are.
Yeah.
Granon has some good taste.
He does.
I know.
We can sprint.
So 50 leaves gives us two bucks.
Actually, I'm going to rake these.
Watch this.
We'll rake them into a big pile and it'll be easier to grab.
Do you have legs now?
I've always had legs.
Well, not always.
But I have legs.
That, you know.
If I, if I'm, if I, you know, if I have enough energy.
spiritual energy.
Prove it!
You don't believe me?
Why would I lie about having legs?
Um, yeah, I have legs.
Jesse!
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you!
I bet she doesn't even have legs.
I only watch VTubers with legs.
Legs.
And furthermore, legs.
legs.
Wait, is this exactly?
Imagine if it were like so...
Whoa!
Bag tying ability.
What's that?
Our yard is becoming so clean.
How do I get in?
Do I climb?
Do you think I can get it in the goal?
In the hoop?
It's a goal.
That's my goal, is to get it in the hoop.
Is there anything else?
Open.
Wait, is it closing?
Oh, it closes very slowly.
Run!
Oh!
Look at that!
Grab.
Throw!
Hold on, hold on.
I got this.
how did we get all the way to legs have we decided if you
have hands i do
three points baby there was a spot in dark souls and where
you had to sit in a bonfire one of your characters legs
would glitch upwards people wrote leg around it that's so
funny oh wow dump a leaf bag from an impressive okay wait
get into the shed acquire bag tying, sprint and crouch.
Crouch, we need to crouch.
I think this is another collectible.
Yeah, we got another one.
Leafy.
Eternity time.
Polish cow is missing.
Only UFO magazine.
Is UFO real thing?
Why do they have so many license plates?
Okay, so I need to start making, I need to, wait, I need to
start then upgrading my hands.
because it seems like we need to tie bags if we rake we're
not tying bags
like if we well rather if we rake into into the vents right
first we rake then we bag you know what yeah let's rake into
a big old pile like i did before we need to upgrade my hands
I said what I said.
Mint got hands.
Catching these hands.
Catch...
Look at my hand.
That's a hand.
Wait, I can even...
I can even show you that whole thing.
That's a hand.
Straight for gripping.
Yeah, that's a hand.
That's a hand.
We got hands up the wazoo.
We got so many hands.
Double hands!
No hands!
I got hands!
Noodle fingers.
Okay, okay.
I mean, what do you expect?
I'm literally... I'm basically jelly.
Why are the hands up there?
Nice hands, boss.
Make sure to wear gloves.
Oh, yeah, I'm cold.
That's why I have my jacket on.
You guys made me take it off.
How can we be so sure if you don't hold it?
Okay, okay, here we go, here we go.
Alright, one of the things was dump a leaf bag from an
impressive distance.
Tie bags full of leaves.
with everything you can.
Oh, I have to tie it.
Okay, there we go.
Now grab it and throw!
Okay, hold on.
Okay, we're just gonna do it like we did before.
Throw.
She's too good.
Watch this.
Was that impressive?
Five meters.
Wait, also it says the entrance is 95.2% complete.
Where am I missing?
Front yard is 100.
Oh, these.
Probably.
Oh, I guess that...
Oh, okay, just kidding.
It's the driveway, so, okay.
Minto is balling.
She's pretty good.
I got the flowers.
I guess it just...
It's counting the driveway.
Oh.
Alright.
She's really good.
This is actually, like, super satisfying.
Of a cape.
Wait, can I upgrade my hands?
We gotta also...
We also have to hit it with, um...
How, though?
They kick like a crazy amount...
Force?
How would I even get it up there?
Huh!
You know?
How?
Hit the basket.
I think you raked some of the elite front leaves over to the
driveway.
Oh, okay.
So it just still counts them, maybe.
I got what you mean.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, well, I'll get picked up anyway, so it doesn't matter.
It don't even matter.
All right, all right.
Now let's see if I do this.
if I do it from here again
does that count oh wait okay now it's seven meters now if I
go back a little bit well actually I want to try from here I
want to see if it adds it you know
no okay we have to do really far away what is this even
possible
from the best skip ball hoop.
Because it made my migraine go away.
Now I can stop watching in Cyclops mode with an eye patch.
No!
We're a St. Glitch face.
I'm glad you're your migraine's going away.
Sorry for pausing.
Um.
Jump too?
Oh dang.
Okay, okay, okay.
Huh!
I think I need to look up higher.
I don't know.
Oh!
Do I need to upgrade my hands?
Huh!
I don't know.
Also, let's upgrade my hands.
We're max, baby.
Sprint and throw, maybe.
Oh, yeah.
We'll sprint.
We'll do all three.
Okay, okay, okay.
Dang it.
The garbage can said, nope.
Yoink.
No, please.
So close.
Oh, okay.
That's what I was like, what the heck?
All right, hold on.
That should have been it.
I think I am, like, I'm not aiming it correctly.
Trying to get the speedrun achievement and this game broke
me.
There's a speedrun?
Wait, there's...
Oh, no.
A speedrun achievement.
Oh, geez.
Yeah!
We did it, baby!
Nice.
Hit the basket with everything you can.
That, I wonder how.
Also, how did the leaves get inside the garage?
Like, to this capacity, it's kind of crazy.
Minto gaming.
Gotta get your head in the game.
Gotta, gotta, gotta get your head in the game.
The garage was a bit open.
I guess that's true.
It was a Todd open.
Now I'm kind of, like, obsessed with doing it like this,
though.
Oh.
Game.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Here, let's finish this area too.
Before I move on to the garage, let's finish one area.
I need to keep our composure.
Shut up!
Leaves are the new gold!
I told you guys!
Scarcity drives the price up!
I told you all!
The stonks!
Now we get 250 for a full bag.
Bye, bye, bye!
It's because there's no trees left because we killed the war
axe.
The Sneed.
That movie was crazy.
That movie was...
I watched it for the first time not too long ago.
like last year I'm pretty sure it was and I was just amazed
at it this is so bizarre how bad can I be like I understand
I kind of get his appeal the Rizzler oh yeah baby I kind of
get his appeal but at the same time the book is better This
should let us into the
shed, right?
Actually, what is the shed?
I just realized there's some on the roof.
Oh, so when you clean up an area, oh, it unlocks the
ability.
I'm just noticing that.
Okay, that's why.
How do you guys think I should, I can get the soccer ball to
touch the basket?
one slur
oh my god it's not my fault they're so similar
i thought it was a fun movie it's just it was just very i
you know i kind of went in with like a different mindset
because of how i know people were about the the the Wensler,
so...
I was like, uh-oh, what if I come out with a new crush?
Get 5,000 leaves.
Nice.
How bad it cannot be?
Tumblr has terrible taste.
I think so.
Oh, dang it.
I thought the lid...
I just need to give up.
I'm not...
I'm never gonna be in the basketball team.
I'm stuck in...
I'm stuck in theater.
I'm never gonna be on the team.
I'm stuck in musical theater like a nerd.
You're just too short for it.
talking to.
I think it was my mom.
She was just like, yeah, I remember when you used to be on
the basketball team.
Because I played basketball as a young ghost.
I only did it because my friend, she was on the team.
No way.
Wow, exactly!
That's crazy.
No one realized he was there.
The Wensler's...
Oh, there you go.
The Wieselower.
How do we...
Okay.
Alright.
We have two things.
Grab.
Can I, like, kick really hard?
No.
There's no, like, build up.
If I kick it, like...
The Twizzler.
Can you grab it?
Yeah, but I can't pick it up.
Sprint kick.
Hold on.
If I can, like, get it perfectly aligned.
I thought it would go, broop.
Do it like Conan.
I need the...
I need it to come out of my pants.
Not my pants, my belt.
Sorry.
No!
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Into it.
No.
Is there a trash can?
Okay, good, good.
Oh, geez.
Six dollars.
Stingy.
I can rest for a bit.
I see a card right there.
This is nice.
Oh, there's a mountain range out there.
Oh, I could get used to this.
Oh, no!
I could get used to something like this.
Yes.
Good.
Wait, do we have new journal things now?
Collect the mysterious photos, hit the basket.
Pire.
Bag tying sprint crouch.
Get into the shed.
What's the shed?
I'm in the basement.
Swings.
Oh, this is the shed.
Okay.
I'm keen for a leaf blower.
We're so close to being able to buy it.
Like, no joke.
Hit the basket, says two out of three.
I know because I know not.
I do it with the soccer ball.
Maybe with the leaf blower, right?
Maybe if we have the leaf blower, we'll be able to do it.
There's gotta be a key in here for the shed, but also how
mysterious this vent is, right?
Unless there's something else that is throwable.
That's very true.
There might be.
Suspicious.
Anyways, how's your guys' weekend going?
How are you guys doing?
Little checkup.
Little checkup of you guys and your lives and afterlives.
Hopefully only lives.
Hopefully no afterlives.
It's a robo-bull in the bottom right.
I'm gonna...
The delivery person stole my food!
Oh!
I've never had that happen, but I also don't use like a
delivery dash very often or anything like that.
That sucks.
Why?
Why would they do that?
I got to sleep in.
Feels great.
Yeah?
I'm fully trapped in traffic.
Oh my gosh, please.
Drive safe.
Don't do not super chat and drive.
I woke up too early.
You can sleep if you want.
Beacons going fine.
It's been consistently negative 40 degrees Fahrenheit
outside.
Also, now I have Gat for the Wensler stuck in my brain.
Thanks, boss.
Sticking out your Gat for the Wensler.
You're so skibbity.
You're so phantom tax.
Have you guys thought about how, like, none of those things
are popular anymore?
like all of those things are not
things just come and go so quickly
meme lifespan is crazy now I still don't even know what the
phantom tax is
I miss six 69 no you have to you get new numbers now
we're subtracting numbers now
the leaf value only going up do calculus while super
chatting so you can super chat and derive
derive how about you minto how you doing i'm great I'm good,
I'm good.
Oh, look.
I know I could make...
Wait, how much was it?
It was $49.99.
Okay.
I was going to say I could just make bags, but we're going
for fast cash.
Phantom tax.
Yeah, if you're sick of...
I think, though, probably those things will be like, you
know...
Old...
funny nostalgic memes for this generation once they're
older.
It's like, oh yeah, remember what everyone was saying.
Everyone was saying six, seven, man.
Times were simpler.
Can I just jump over this?
We bought it.
The leaf blower.
Holy, even the upgrades for it are expensive.
Wait, hold on.
Let's test it here.
Uh-oh.
It's a little chaotic.
I can't really control where they go.
Sometimes they get inside the door.
Sometimes they go over into this pile.
I never need to rake again, I think.
The money is just...
It's flowing in.
Oh, the soccer ball!
Oh, wow.
I don't think it's gonna work.
I think it's too...
It's too slow.
It's like too not powerful at all.
People will say six, seven to their grandkids while laughing
and getting embarrassed blank stares in return.
The Gen Z stair.
I don't know, I think they'll stare back first.
I think everybody will just be staring at each other.
Let's close that.
No, close.
There we go.
G.
The Gen G.
Stare G.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
I don't know.
I feel like people get on kids a lot nowadays, but I
think...
think there were some really stupid things that older old a
lot of older memes were pretty dumb as
well they're just nostalgic to you so they're funnier
memes are exclusively dumb yeah i think what gets uh i think
what's like i guess nowadays it feels more like shoved in
your face all the time because it's like if you're on if
you're online you're just like oh my gosh all I see is this
thing and so they get it's like beaten down like it's just
beating a dead horse like crazy and then that's why they die
because everybody does it for like two weeks and then it's
done we're planking there were kids out there planking on
various items we were all having.
It's all silly.
The kids, the children crave whimsy.
Maybe.
They just don't realize.
They crave whimsy, but they don't know.
The memes, Jeff.
Like, I, oh my gosh, remember when they made, like, rage
comics into books and stuff for school.
They were like, why you know homework?
I wish I did it.
Me gusto.
My cringe moments are going to the grave with me.
being cringe, something about being free.
Oh, I get it, though.
Don't tell us all.
They don't need to know.
I feel like the leaves like in the corners here are kind of
dangerous.
You can't see them.
Lucky for me, all of my cringe moments are recorded on live
stream.
Well, maybe not all of my cringe moments, but a good
majority of them I can never escape I feel like even though
the the leaf blower was great it just caused like a whole
mess now like before I felt very organized now all my leaves
are kind of like everywhere we love those moments though I'm
so glad I I'm so glad that I can make you guys feel better
about yourselves.
Like, man.
She's just really dumb.
So glad that I'm smarter than this ghost girl.
No wonder she's dead.
I didn't mean to punch it.
Roll!
Hope he can return the favor every so often.
Yeah.
I'd pay to watch those cringe moments.
My cringe moments!
No.
Clear.
And throw!
Yeah.
We almost have enough for some...
Oh wait, we do have enough for some...
I only got, like...
Here, we'll do these.
And I'll do...
Yeah, we'll do that.
for prosperity forever and ever until the YouTube servers go
down I
wonder what it would be like the next YouTube kind of crazy
so many have tried and so many have failed many have tried
and all have failed YouTube too yeah I mean nobody thought
anybody could could take out Minecraft and here we are high
tail I kind of really love Hytale, though.
So far, it's so fun.
Oh, my gosh.
I see her cringe moments and go, dang, I gotta be more
whimsical.
Look how happy she is.
What have we got in here?
Get into the shed.
Buy all upgrades.
Acquire bag tying, sprint and crouch.
Hit the basket.
Okay.
Yeah.
Isn't Daily Motion technically older?
Is Daily Motion...
Yeah, but like, I mean, there can always be there will
always be like another video site but something that will
take over like as like the popularity of youtube i don't
know man youtube would i feel like at this point it feels
like youtube literally has to die to you know it's not be
popular anymore but everybody i mean at the same time nobody
a lot of people don't use facebook anymore there was a time
when i think i would have never thought facebook would not
be like the main platform you know what i mean i have to
make some really bad moves oh yeah new youtube making bad
moves they would never i'm sorry i'm sorry youtube don't
listen to me i love your platform don't make me go to twitch
I should probably, like, rake this.
Let's do that.
Or, actually, blow!
I wish I liked Twitch more, but I don't.
I feel like the big thing for me is, like, all the...
all the, um...
Integrations with Twitch are pretty fun.
And I think there are some platform, or some, like,
companies that are trying to do that with YouTube.
So maybe, you know, and I don't mean like...
I won't do like a text-to-speech.
I mean, I think you could do that on YouTube anyway.
But more like...
Like, you play a game and your chat can play with you kind
of deal or stuff like that.
I think those are really fun.
But those are all pretty just...
Just Twitch.
Oh, we can crouch!
We're sneaking!
Yes.
Sneak.
I boost play Pokemon yeah that would be a great stream for
when I am like away that would be a great stream for when I
am like on vacation or well I say vacation but I don't know
the last time I took a vacation when I am away from my
computer streaming
ads during the stream irritate me oh my god and they're so
they're like the worst too they're like yeah no I 100% get
it YouTube gives me actually I think they're well I think
the ad button on YouTube doesn't even work like I think it
doesn't give ads to people I think I boost playing a game
would be far more cohesive than some other fan base You
think so?
I believe in you guys.
I always believe in you guys.
I'm your number one cheerleader.
Never forget that.
You're just like, I don't know if I can do this.
Always think, wait.
Minto thinks I can do this.
I am always cheering for you guys.
Thank you.
of course I just have so much faith in you guys maybe too
much shed roof oh
all right let's get some upgrades on our let's see all right
we have one dollar left let's go so
we can can crouch now, but... Oh, all right.
Oh, okay.
That works too.
Whoa.
Can I jump over this?
No.
Oh, wow.
This place is beautiful, and it's quiet, you know?
Quiet.
It's so quiet.
There's like, none of the neighbors are being annoying or
loud, except me.
I'm the when being loud and annoying because I'm
leaf-blowing.
It's so serene.
Is this what it is like living in a neighborhood?
I recently just published my first scientific paper.
I wanted to say thank you.
My kamioshi for your huge source of inspiration.
Mito kudo!
What the heck?
Cool potato!
You're so cool!
Scientific.
You're smart!
Wow!
See?
This is what I mean.
I have the most faith in you guys.
That's so awesome!
Congratulations!
Ibu in high places.
That's awesome!
Wait, oh, I'm...
And thank you so much for the pink too!
You should be celebrating!
What delicious food!
It's so funny.
I got like, you know, I prepared my maid cafe for the
potential ice of everything, the snow storms.
And I'm like, but all I want is everything that I didn't buy
for food.
It took about two years of learning machining, but just
yesterday I finally made my first thing for other people
that I engineered.
That's not a prototype.
And now they want me to design more things to sell!
Oh my gosh, Senshi!
What the heck?
You guys are, like, actual geniuses?
We have real geniuses in the chat.
Oh my gosh, that's so awesome!
Congrats!
So many Twitch VTubers I'd like to watch but can't because
all the TTS and alerts cause my sensory overload.
way.
I prefer a much more like classic kind of just a normal type
stream.
Like I understand like it's very fine with all the bells and
whistles but and it's you know it's not that I'm like I
don't want to say lazy about it.
Like I don't want people to think like oh she doesn't add
all these things to her stream because like she's just lazy.
I just actually prefer like such a regular experience.
Naoki!
Thank you!
You're an old school gal.
I really am.
Thanks to you, Minto.
We were able to to to keep me sane while I was painting an
airport in Wyoming.
What the heck?
Painting an airport.
That sounds like a big task.
That sounds like, oh my gosh, don't say that.
Some dev is gonna be listening in chat and it's just like,
Painting an airport.
That sounds like a game idea.
Wait.
I was trying to get it through the wall.
Takes notes.
Some dev is going to be like, oh yeah, we need another leaf.
Leaf it alone.
We need another power wash.
Honestly, though, like I said, these games are so
satisfying.
There's a bajillion clones.
Because they're very great for streaming.
And they're satisfying.
So I honestly don't mind.
Airport painting simulator.
Yes, this has potential.
Everybody's getting in on it now.
Somebody's got to do it first.
Oh no!
The gate doesn't say oh.
Okay, we got a hand.
We got a hand do this.
We were trained here.
We were trained for this.
House flipper.
Yeah!
Very house flipper, right?
Except it's an airport.
Kobe!
That should have been in.
Baggage check simulator.
There's this new game.
Quarantine something something.
Um, that's...
I like those kinds of, like, paper please types games, too.
They're just, like, puzzly enough, you know what I mean?
And, like, kind of keep your attention.
The zombie one!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can I hire you to do my yard next?
It feels, like, negative 5 degrees Fahrenheit outside, and I
don't want to.
Why my ectoplasm will freeze?
Yeah, I'm a big fan of those types of games.
Pre-check people for zombie virus.
Yeah, it looks fun.
Like, papers, please.
No, I'm not human is kind of like that, too.
I'm working on my first novel.
Oh, my gosh.
Pitch it us.
Pitch it to us, Wally.
I unlocked the grill.
The grill?
Is this the grill?
Oh.
Can I grill?
Is this area just a grill?
Unlock the leisure area.
We'll do air spread.
What's this one?
Cute.
This kitchen's not the same with...
Out you!
There we go.
We found what we need for the basket.
It's just a spoon.
It's just a greasy grill.
Without you.
Oh my god, the collision.
Oh my god.
I'm really...
Oh my god, please.
This thing is huge.
Now put the load.
shit in the basket.
Yeah!
Hit a basket with a basketball.
Beach ball and a leaf bag.
We did it!
As soon as I saw it, I was like, I know.
I know what must be dying.
Alright.
We're gonna fix you.
$10!
Oh no, there's a hedge maze?
Okay, wait.
Okay, rich guy no wonder you can afford being in a coma not
all of us can afford being in a coma now there are hedge
maze in the backyard yeah why am i having to deal with hedge
maces two days in a row
this awesome needs to be repaired jennifer thank you gotta
get you to one million subs one sub at a big chat thank you
if it happens that'd be pretty cool
all right let's get the pool one maybe working first and
then wait what am i doing we'll just we'll just start grab
we'll just start grabbing because once we get the pool one i
can start blowing stuff into the pool and this one's a
little bit easier to
to do I think though I wish there were I wish there were a
trash can in here
I don't really think about it though the um you know sub
stuff like that like it'd be like obviously I would be super
ultra grateful but you know as as you know even though this
is my job i try not to be like i'm i'm failing because i
haven't reached a one billion subscribers you know what i
mean honestly
i feel like i do very well for my little self so i think i
think we're doing all right i think we're doing okay guys
bye bye Thank you so much for the thank you, the thank you.
The single leaf.
It mocks me.
All right, watch this.
Come on.
All right, do we have enough money?
Yes.
All right, watch it happen.
Oh, yeah.
So satisfying.
We're already at 32 blocks, guys.
Crazy.
It's like all the money in the world.
We're, well, finally, we're dollar by dollar.
scent by scent, we will be able to pay off our nine-year
coma dead.
Leaves are in!
We're gonna be rich, baby.
Yeah!
Oh, yeah.
Feels good.
Hot dog.
Hot dog, indeed!
Even if it takes a while, we look at the new to the support.
Love you.
All I could ask for!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Let's see.
Garage?
I feel like I'm missing something.
Global economic domination, one leaf at a time.
Yeah, baby!
I'm gonna get two upgrades.
Wait, what just popped?
Something just popped.
5!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts and thanks!
you yeah mom said i can have two upgrades mosquito
in your ear
the pool is at 69 percent nice is this a way for
nice i feel like i'm not doing this most efficient way but
you know what it doesn't matter we're still making the cash
money like sometimes the leaves just don't blow in like but
look at all the money we're making baby wait what's the next
oh let's do decreases the time required to blow the leaves
off oh i've just been buying the upgrades not even thinking
about it you know what actually hold on we'll buy these And
we can rake some too, because I feel like raking some of
this would be good also.
I'm just buying stuff.
I'm not even reading what it does.
I'm like, yeah, it's more upgrades.
It doesn't matter.
You can't see the money?
Let me move you guys over.
I'll move you guys over to the other side.
Wait, it's so lonely.
There's like nothing over here, though.
There's like just kind of the...
Like I've just been blocking this part.
You guys are so far away.
Put us back.
No, you have to see the money.
I wonder how many more.
Oh, I guess the hedge maze.
And then...
How do you even speedrun this game?
What is the speedrun for this game?
Also, how do they not, how does this not like clog their,
their vents?
Pick up leafs, but bash.
Put us in the big portal.
Good times.
No, no, go this way.
Go that way.
I'm just like trying to move them.
I have like a lot of individual leaves, you know?
Not idea.
To any percent is 20 minutes!
That's wild!
20 minutes!
Giving the leaves to the bowl, man.
Yeah.
Well, they pay top dollars, so.
They can take it all they want.
The leaf blower has its faults.
It's great, but it does have its faults.
The head of the rake really is small, isn't it?
It's average.
Why are you getting it?
Why are you taking it out so personally, right, Snat?
The pool was cold.
Wait, how have I not completed the pool?
Oh.
Is it me or is it getting?
Oh, gosh.
You know, everything we saw was blue.
So now it's like ultra orange.
Oh, my God.
Orange.
You, whoa, yeah, ultra orange.
I said what I said.
If you guys didn't know, UOs, like the things that people
break at concerts, that are really...
The glow sticks, the UO stands for Ultra Orange.
So if you get like a UV, it's like ultraviolet.
It's an office romance about a guy befriending a smart but
shy skunk woman.
That's your, what your novel's about!
I'm in.
Give me the lightie.
Let me have her.
Ugh, this sucks.
I should have blown all of this.
I don't know why didn't I blow all of this into the pool.
It ain't too late.
Even though you have almost half a million subs, you still
give off that cozy, smaller streamer energy, which is great.
I'm glad you're thinking that.
We need UM sticks, Ultra Minto.
Ultra Minto.
I'm already Ultra Minto.
I'm gonna become the Joker.
I'm going to become the Joker.
Crap, grab, grab.
I guess what we could do, what would be more efficient is
blowing them this way.
Joining them with their other brethren.
Into the vent.
All leaves must be vented.
Wait, can I blow the...
Oh, imagine if I, like, was able to blow the leaves from the
other side.
It'd be kind of crazy.
Why are you guys doing clown?
What did I say?
Oh, the Joker.
That's right.
Yeah, I did say that.
I didn't say I was gonna become the Joker.
Oh.
I didn't say I've become the Joker.
I just gotta keep on picking up.
Alright, alright, alright.
We got this?
A bag?
How nostalgic?
What?
Are you like, oh, my childhood of...
of...
breaking the leaves.
One thing I don't really understand is, like, why...
People don't like...
having foliage in their yards like why why did like a yard
with no trees no bushes like grass only become like such an
ideal aesthetic to people i don't i don't quite get it like
i guess like
i guess like yeah there are like certain bugs and stuff that
like it prevents from stuff but i don't i just i'm like you
have no you're you they have no personality but also like at
the same time i get like you know when you see really high
grass you're like oh my gosh i understand that i blew all of
this in here just to pick it up with my hands in the end
i bet the hoa is that full i agree
and bushes have to be looked after.
Yeah, that's true, that's true.
That is very true.
All right, blow, blow, blow away, blow, blow away.
I'm sure landscaping is nice or IMO, but sometimes it's HOA
maintenance or neighborhoods just to new for stuff.
Wait, how, wait, I can't read.
What?
I can't take it up here!
Oh my gosh.
Too new for stuff.
Oh!
Right, right, right.
I understand.
Oh, we have $41.
Let's upgrade.
Precision, I think, is important.
I can't write.
Your reading is fine.
Sometimes...
Thank you, Dargo.
you can write I can't read that's the cold hard facts the
cold hard facts of it okay so besides the photos which we
have five
I wish it would tell us if we oh we have a greenhouse secret
room and we have a maze wait I'm sorry did that say 29 000
leaves i'm sorry
this people were saying you could get this you could finish
this game in two hours i'm letting you guys know that the
green house is orange house orange and red and yellow house
that's a lot of leaves when they say leave it alone they
mean definitely that area well not 100% oh they did the
reviews were like yeah you can 100% this game in two hours I
think they're beasts I think I think everybody who's doing
that okay I usually don't like to say that somebody doesn't
have a life but oh my god what are you a leaf blowing pro
they lied as easily as they leafed might be slightly more
efficient what are you talking about I am peak efficiency I
even meant to leave that one leaf right there unattended
you've never seen more efficiency in your afterlife ever
life sorry you guys are alive I'm the dead one my bad leaf
blowing is their life they are extremely serious How's your
week been, Minto?
My week's been okay.
Not bad at all.
I
mean, like, I get that you're not...
You have to, like, get all the leaves, though, to unlock the
next area.
That's the thing.
So I'm like, I feel like to beat the game, you have to 100%
it, no?
She doesn't know about the leaves, Skip.
Maybe there's like skips.
Let me in.
Wall jumps.
Well, we're at 75%.
I feel like that deserves a...
That's all we need, though.
Playing with a leaf blower.
Squidward...
Flying with a leaf blower.
was the pool at 99.2% 99.1% I think it's because some of the
leaves from the pool got mixed up with our leaves in here so
I think that's how that works for some reason they don't
count them as the I guess because that would like make it
more than a hundred percent, right?
So they become, they stay leaves of the pool.
Flying with a leaf blower.
So funny.
No, please.
Please leaf.
I wish the value of the leaves would go up, though.
I'm getting a tattoo of you on Monday.
What?
That's gonna be on your body.
Oh, see, see, see.
Some of the pool leaves went in there.
That's gonna be on your body forever.
Unless you laser it off.
But that's even more money.
That's crazy.
I can't wait to see them.
get in there get in there like some of these I'm obviously
just gonna grab with my hand these guys in here they're
pissing me off so
we'll just grab them oh gosh if I can oh geez oh geez oh
geez
one leaf out of time literally Quite literally one leaf at a
time.
Yeah.
There we go.
A little more.
A little bit more to the left.
Yeah.
Around the table.
The tables are my demise.
Right there?
Yes!
I think that's all of them.
Yippee!
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep grabbing with my hands until I fill this
up.
Okay.
summoning salt to give us leaf at a load speed run history
what is that who is that
what is like the most popular game to speed run is it mario
i feel like super mario is really popular
Metroid Minecraft Oh Yeah Yeah
Minecraft at the moment Oh crazy
I know it's late It's not as easy picking up with my hands
But it feels a bit faster than trying to direct it Into the
hole Not as efficient but Yeah
Speed running seems fun, but speed running Minecraft is
always fun because especially if it's like, you know, not
like a specific seed.
And so, you know, it's a completely random run.
It's always fun to see, I think.
Don't forget you have a rake.
Can it get in there?
I don't even know.
Maybe it can.
I don't know.
The tables are my demise, for real.
Okay, alright, here we go.
That was it, right?
Wait, what did I miss?
Oh, oh, a single leaf.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Power, more max power, let's go.
Well spotted, thank you.
And the pool?
100% let's go.
Oh wait, no pool is still 99.
Oh no.
Guys, I'm missing a single...
There.
Oh!
There's a great video called Minecraft in 20 seconds.
Explain in 20 minutes that you might...
enjoy if you ever need a video essay i always i'll check it
out thank you one leaf what oh my god whoa it's so skinny in
here oh i can't fix it i can't fix it yet no one leaf or
another i'm gonna find you i gotta get jankin jankin jankin
one leaf Oh, and now I do.
Oh, yeah.
Ooh.
Can I open this then?
Awesome.
Is this prepared?
No.
All right, time to start hand grabbing again.
thought i heard you bring him up once must have been someone
else summoning salt is a youtuber that makes long videos on
the history of certain speedrun categories for games i might
have watched him before and i just don't remember you're
totally good though flufeos i am a casual speedrunner
enjoyer
casual speedrunner enjoyer
really big during the pandemic
popular speedrun.
Oh, I guess it's, well.
Portal.
Huh.
That's really surprising.
Even after all this time that portal would still be?
My dead Oshi, she cleaned so well.
I am a maid after all.
It doesn't feel like so many leaves here like it does, but
it doesn't at the same time.
Low entry barrier, short run.
That's true.
It's also a Barney game where one of the speedrun categories
is any percent no controller.
Play itself if you leave it alone and just RNG how quickly
it finishes.
Should we try that?
What if we got the speedrun?
What if we got the world record?
Yeah, I was like, I also was thinking Barney from Half-Life
or Barney the Dino?
Should we Barney game?
Barney game for the Sega Genesis?
What the hell?
That's crazy.
I do know that we have enough.
Wait, do we?
We have enough for this one over, not this one.
This is 25, I think, over here.
Oh, see!
Happy birthday!
One second, let me sing.
Is this VOD?
Not the VOD.
I am dead, but I am here.
Happy birthday to you.
to you happy birthday dear us me happy birthday to you happy
birthday wait let's check the journal too enter the jungle
welcome to the jungle infiltrate the secret room interesting
Now that I have better precision and stuff, this is way
easier.
Oh
yeah!
Nice.
Nice!
Just go down the tunnel.
So fast.
I know.
We've got lots of leaves.
Oh, welcome to the jungle.
Where nobody lives.
They leave?
They leave, but they don't leave.
Oh, yeah.
That was awesome.
But the leaves are leaving.
Closing time.
You don't have to go home, but you can't leave here.
How many?
How many songs can we incorporate leaf into?
I'm not gonna bother with these guys.
There we go, okay.
Actually, I'm not gonna lie.
I think there's enough here that I could just grab a ball.
Nice.
Upgrade strength.
Oh, okay.
Wait, the maze is already 100%.
Oh my gosh, speed run.
Speedrun real?
Okay, $40 for the airstream with I believe I can fly I
believe I can touch the sky I think about every now and then
My leaves going into the vent
Too good
Yeah, let's just blow everything out of here.
You know?
Such a silly stream.
Well, we're silly people.
Anything can be a silly stream.
If you're silly enough.
Remember the whimsy in your lives, everybody.
Remember the whimsy in your lives.
Remember who you are.
Thanks, Peter Pan.
What is that supposed to mean?
I kind of wish it just sucked up the leaves rather than me
having to, like, blow it, you know?
Like, it kind of does if it's really close within proximity,
but it doesn't always.
Like, look, these are right in front of it, and they just...
Not strong enough.
I am Minky's silliest soldier.
Silly soldier reporting for duty?
What would a silly duty be?
Maybe this game.
Wait a second.
What time is the denser to collab at?
In 45 minutes!
Oh no!
Guys, we got a speedrun.
I thought I would be able to beat it.
be able to beat the game we might just be able to get into
the secret spot and then
leafing on a jet plane what's that one we were too silly we
were too silly
oh my gosh vtuber your optimization is so poor
area and just clear it.
That's what we'll do.
Maybe it like a leaf.
Wait, what this?
Oh.
We have $70.
Hold on.
We gotta get upgrades, upgrades, upgrades.
46.
We could do that easy.
Speedrunning is super cool.
They even do charity events.
Yeah, I love AGDQ.
Silly.
Too close to the sun.
Thank you guys for the super chats.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
I'm Mintiana Grande.
Yeah.
Silly too close to the sun.
Always having too much fun.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, beautiful.
Get sucked.
All right.
Out of the greenhouse.
Everybody out of the greenhouse.
It's a good thing that I was in a coma for nine years
because all my plants died.
Greenhouse is basically emptied.
Wait.
Upgrade.
We gotta get stuff out of here too.
I'm gonna just grab it from underneath.
I think it'll be too difficult to...
You heard her here, folks.
What did I say?
What am I saying?
Don't listen to me.
I'm a silly person on the internet.
I literally speak no facts.
I've never said the truth in my life.
Okay.
Now, why is there a hole here?
She lies for a living.
I'm convinced they're still in a coma.
I know.
What a silly dream.
You ever think of, like, games that are, like, so silly?
You're just, like, where did this concept come from?
Like, was it a dream?
I had a dream last night.
I was trying to get back to a hotel.
And, um...
And, uh...
There was, like, a coffee convention on the way to my hotel,
and, like, I went inside, and they were, like, it was, like,
Starbucks, and, like, Dunkin' Donuts, and just, like, a
bunch of coffee place, and they're, like, they were, like,
bombarding me, being, like, you have to try our coffee!
Like, going real crazy at it.
I was, like, and then, also, um, what was, there's, like,
uh, Vicky?
but not Denzetsu Vicky.
Vicky from fairly odd parents was there and I saw her on a
date.
I don't know the last time I ever thought about that, lady.
I've been collecting too many thermoses.
No, never enough.
Can I upgrade?
Yes.
Okay, now all we have to do is upgrade Max and we'll have
that.
All upgrades.
Clean up all leaves.
Wait, I haven't found a mysterious photo here.
A photo.
Kingdom Hearts must have been a dream.
Oh, I got one with that on their own.
I liked Vicky when I was a kid.
She's, like, evil, though, no?
You have a tie?
Do you ever think about, like, the characters that you
had...
crushes on as a kid and think about how like they influence
you like to have a type in the modern day like you know who
was hot uh the girl from foster's home for imaginary friends
oh my god she was so stinking cute
Frankie Frankie she was like my oh my gosh i wanted to i was
like i want to be like her she was so cool so cute
please we're already well greenhouse is 80 percent
raven teen titans yeah yeah yeah yeah
Are you from Freemora?
Oh, it's...
Oh, yeah.
Who's like a big, like, character that Japanese kids had a
crush on, I wonder?
Like Shin-chan's mom.
Does anybody have...
Did anyone have a crush on Marge Simpson?
I guess that's the equivalent of having a crush.
crush on oh my god i thought the scarecrow was a person it's
the equivalent of having a crush on shin chan's mom where is
that is the little thing i wonder the mysterious picture
wait i just realized our greenhouse is broken i think we
really have been in a coma for nine years we had someone
tending emptying our they were emptying our home they were
like this guy's not gonna make it but they didn't bother to
clean up all the uh the leaves for us thanks a lot I have a
crush on Homer Simpson understandable we love a good family
man is this whole area the greenhouse oh it is okay nice
wait let's upgrades yeah we're upgraded one of my earliest
animated crushes was Starfire from Teen Titans she was
incredibly adorable in that car she really was and Misty
from Polk Misty I bet a lot of people had crushes on Misty
yes yes yes but a lot of people had crushes on Misty lean
the inverse some whoa whoa She was very cute too.
I don't blame you.
Guys, we're so close.
We're so stinking close.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh.
Wait, what am I gonna do with all this money now?
I'm rich and I have nowhere to do it.
No way to use it.
Wait, can I go into the secret room?
Or do I have to unlock it?
Okay.
Kagome from Inuyasha is still goaded.
Now, were you guys a Kagome?
Or were you a Kikyo?
In terms of looks, I preferred Kikyo.
In terms of everything else, I preferred Kagome.
Sango?
Oh my gosh, Sango is...
Yeah, you're right.
You're so right.
Sango.
Shoo.
I'm just Moroku, I think.
I think I'm that guy.
Okay, making sure there's no more leaves under there.
I'm just going to pick these up with my hands.
I'm speedrunning this, you guys.
I'm going like fast as lightning.
Well, speedrun is maybe as I pick up one leaf at a time.
Maybe not correct, but I'm going to...
I'm going fast.
Bubbles for Powerpuff Girls.
Did anyone develop any fetishes because, or realize they had
a fetish because of, um, totally spies?
Something's been happening here.
Wait!
I'm looking for the secret.
For the cards, though.
I'm looking up in the trees.
up in the leaves
because I don't think I don't think we got the cards for
everything never got a chance to watch totally spies there's
actually there was I don't know if it's still up but there
was a 24 hour like live stream of it that sometimes like in
Japan and I'll like put on like cartoon live streams you
know because it's it's on 24 7 and I can just I can just
vibe do you guys see it they really hit these guys well
show us cool outside of the fest stuff
I think it was cool with it too I'm just kidding no I sat in
the grass looking up at the Because Mimi from Digimon wasn't
real.
She would never know how much I loved her.
She's Burger Paladin.
I did that too.
But with Inuyasha.
I would...
I had this small little hill in my backyard.
And I would go out at night.
Or like at sunset around that time.
And I would like lay on it.
And I would look up at the sky.
And I would be like.
Why won't he come to me?
like why why won't he recognize me and see me all right
let's go into the secret room i give up on the cards wait
let me cash out first i swear if there's a bunch of this is
gonna it's gonna be filled with squirrels probably
it's gonna be filled with spoils I bet.
Squirrel party.
Oh.
It's the point of no return.
Uh-oh.
I'm scared.
Where are they?
Why is it so smoky?
My house is on fire.
I'm trapped?
Wait, what the hell?
What is going on?
Oh!
they're manufacturing the leaf it's coming from people I've
been cleaning up people's skin it is that's good
in two hours crazy what did I miss click collect all
mysterious photos earn an immense number of check leaves
seven hundred dollars complete the game without repairing
any leaf inlets oh wow complete the game in under 40 minutes
complete all objectives in the game Wow.
They were doing it.
I knew it was them.
I knew it was the squirrels.
I knew it.
Yay!
Wow.
There actually is like a completed version of this game.
We beat the game.
We beat Leaf It Alone.
What's the rankings?
Who's number?
one we'll never know wait resume oh my clean house I feel
like it definitely got darker no it definitely got like more
nighttime it's a sunset for sure it was definitely like
daytime and as we progressed as we progressed the Sun
started setting it's cute it was so cute
Squales, they must live in the league with the dog from
Silent Hill Thank you from Batman Beyond really cemented my
love for goo girls Wait, I don't know her Hi, I'm it Wife is
watching you as I'm about to step out Please shout hi to
Floor Or not Hello, hello Look her up Okay, hold on
She's hot.
Oh, she's gooey.
I'm seeing some interesting photos.
Crushed hard on Pink Ranger and Gadget from... Gadget was so
cute.
Now I'm married to cute nerdy brunette.
So, hmm.
Dreams do come true.
Well, guys, I gotta get going because...
um i have a collab with densestu.exe on the densestu channel
we will be writing into it but thank you guys so so much for
leave it alone this was this was fine this was cute i really
really appreciate it so i will see you guys uh hopefully
thank you so much for the big feeling thank you never
expected the ending it was so funny so what about our coma
then huh oh to meet thank you everybody thank you thank you
bye bye bye bye bye see you see you bye bye